how many of you have attended
celebrity parties i haven't
right well if you can't mit professors
being celebrities i've been to a lot of
them
but that's that's not the case
right um people don't
don't really think of us as celebrities
which is fine with me
so this this puzzle is uh i call it the
best time to party
and
i'm having a little trouble erasing uh
uh you're right there's another one
all right well i'm probably gonna run
out of this
but you know what this time i'll i'll
use i don't think i need this
super thick chalk this is slightly i'll
use this one
um
so the setup here with all of these
things there's always a little bit of
setup
is you got a ticket to this party
there are going to be all these
celebrities and
it's a time ticket uh with some
flexibility
you only get to stay for a certain
amount of time before you have to leave
and other people are going to come in
and hop not with these celebrities but
you get to pick
at the particular time that you go right
and so initially we'll set things up in
a fairly straightforward way
we're going to say that you have
an hour a particular hour you know maybe
it's six to seven
seven to eight what have you you get to
choose that's part of the puzzle
how do you pick the best time to party
and
you do have a schedule and amazingly
these celebrities
are going to stick to those schedules
but the schedule has been published
i with respect to when particular
celebrities are going to be at this
party
right and as you can imagine
as the title of the puzzle gives away
you i want to choose the hour such that
the maximum number of celebrities so you
you're uh
uh not particularly uh interested in uh
uh in in uh particular celebrities or
one specific celebrity
uh you just wanna sort of max out you
know number of selfies so you can put it
on your facebook page instagram what
have you
uh and uh you have that schedule and
you're trying to optimize
the number right so uh here you go
uh we're going to have a
let's say let's just solve this again
manually first
and then we'll think of algorithms
we're going to have intervals again
and so
think of these as ours you know beyonce
comes in at six leaves at seven
taylor from seven through nine
brad 10 11
kd 10 to 12.
tom
8 to 10.
going to render a room here all right so
that's the schedule that's published
right and we can think of these as ours
comes and goes there's one small
subtlety
which is i'm going to think of these as
closed intervals on the left hand
and open at the right end so it's all
that means is
um if this is 6 p.m and if you come in
at 6 p.m
on the dot uh well you certainly get to
see beyonce and if you come in at 6 59
you get to see beyonce but if you come
in at seven uh
she's gone right um and the same thing
with uh
a tailor at nine so you have to um
uh you you have to choose your time uh
properly right so
um what's uh what's the best time you
get to go for any hour that you choose
what's the best time to go to get the
maximum number of selfies
anyone you can do this uh manually use i
tell me how uh tell me tell me what the
about the time is
and then i'll ask you what your
algorithm was
right so someone who hasn't hasn't
answered yet
yep uh either six o'clock or ten o'clock
either six logarithm what's your name oh
kevin right
sorry you'd um yeah the other cabin
right so um six o'clock or ten o'clock
because it's six o'clock so who are the
people you'd see at six o'clock
that's only two yeah
so can you do better than two can
someone do better than
what kevin did
yeah go ahead kenosha um
yes so you could do three at 10 o'clock
you'd get brad
you'd get katie and then you'd also get
drake
okay so that's three okay so um
that's that's the best you can do uh in
in this uh in this puzzle
right but you know you might you may
have hundreds of celebrities and you
want to pick the right time
so obviously we want to write a computer
program here right um what
uh algorithm kevin or um kanishka did
you use to do this
uh how do you do it in your head um
did you go either either one of you did
you go hour by hour
did you go six o'clock how many people
are there or or
did you try and intersect or what did
you do
well what's that what's a natural um
what's a what's a reasonable way of
proceeding here right
what's a reasonable way of proceeding
uh someone other than yeah back there
[Music]
the frequent amount of time so look at
look at the hours look you say
you you say six o'clock and and you try
and see how many sixes are up there or
yeah
right what's your name nisha so nisha
says she's going to go look
for six o'clock and see if how many
sixes are up there
right and there's two sixes up there and
you know maybe that's why kevin said six
right
um on the other hand um clearly you know
that didn't quite work
right uh in in this case because uh
what what happened was at ten o'clock
there's only two of those and so that
looks good too six and ten
but you miss the fact that ten exists in
between uh in in
in nine and eleven correct so you're not
explicitly seeing these things
right so um but that gives you an
algorithm i mean it does give you an
algorithm the algorithm is
um let me go ahead and do a little bit
uh
better than what you described a little
more
relaxed check right it's not just an
identical
i want 6 to be in the table
but i want to see if 6 is contained in
the
interval associated with any particular
celebrity
correct so if i did 6 i'd say 6 is
contained in this interval
it's not contained in this interval not
not not
not yes right so i'd get 2.
and then when i finally got to 10 i'd
get
contained contain contained and i'd get
3.
right so um there's clearly an algorithm
here that depends on the
the number of hours that you're looking
at depends really uh
on the granularity of time okay so
uh this this particular algorithm would
say
i let me go ahead and enumerate
at the different times that um i could
possibly go
i could start at six i could start at uh
seven but i may be able to start at 6
30. i could go from 6 30 to 7 30. maybe
that's
you're allowed to do that right um the
point is
if you stick with the original
description you could go ahead and
enumerate
6 through 12 and then you could generate
a bunch of different numbers
associated with the number of
celebrities and you can go ahead and
pick
uh what uh what time you want to go
right um so this is look it's it's a
little bit like
our previous puzzle in the sense that
there's a
a a relatively straightforward strategy
that enumerates
different hours and goes through and
does a bunch of computation
and then picks the maximum in this case
previously it was the minimum for you
will all confirm here is the maximum
right um what is the disadvantage of
this this particular algorithm that we
just described
what is one potential disadvantage
right yep
go ahead fine well i mean like it's not
linear so you have to make multiple
passes on like for example like you have
both like
first of all you have to enumerate all
of the possible times and then for every
time you have to go through the list
uh like over and over again that's right
so there's a lot of computational
uh combinations and this is
this is a lot of conversation there's a
computational overhead
um i'll uh let me show you what the code
looks like
for the straightforward algorithm all
right
and so it's it's going to again uh be
in intuitive um it's going to do exactly
what we just described right
and so if you look at what you have up
there schedule
up there is is simply a set of
a set of intervals right and um
they're tuples and so i have something
that's bigger than this example here
but it includes that and there's a whole
bunch of things in there um and now
i'm going to look at um this is just a
start time for a particular celebrity
and this is the end time for that
celebrity i'm just setting that up
and and i'm going to go ahead and um i i
i'm looking at
um for each um
c in schedule i'm going to look at this
i'm going to look at that i'm going to
look at that
i'm going to figure out what the uh the
the start time is
and the the the end this and
i'm just doing this simply because um i
want to figure out
what the earliest um what what the
what the earliest start time for any of
these celebrities are so in this case
it's six
and the latest time that a celebrity is
is around is 12
right so that's all that this first
thing does it's just it's just finding
the
the range that i have to deal with okay
so there's not much there
um i'm going to go ahead and compute
what's called the celebrity
density and i'll show you the code for
that but that's essentially
what we described which is for a
particular hour
between start and end how many
celebrities do i see at that particular
hour
right and then for the next hour how
many celebrities do i see i'm just
calling it the
the the density right um
and and then um the count is
uh is is a is a list that is going to
have celebrity densities for particular
times
that correspond to the indices of count
and i'm just going to go through that
list and i'm going to figure out the the
time that has max count or the maximum
number of celebrities
okay and there's a couple of different
ways of doing that don't worry about
that
but i'm happy to answer questions if um
if you have them and then i just say you
know the
best time to attend the party is at this
time
time which was discovered here and the
number of celebrities
who are going to be attending is
maxcount okay so so this is
essentially the code for for for the
algorithm and
this thing here is is doing
the slightly more relaxed check
that that i alluded to which was like
when you have six o'clock
uh you're not just looking for six here
um you're looking for six within this
interval that looks like this so 6 is
definitely within this
but it would not be
6 is not
is not inside 5 and 6 as i described to
you before
right so that's simply the check that's
why you have a less than
equal to here and a strictly greater
than over here
just to take care of that uh closed and
open part of it
right so um again that if you don't
understand every nuance in this code
it's not that big a deal but hopefully
you have
the overall picture right uh makes sense
right okay so as you can imagine there's
a much better way
okay there's there's a much better way
that isn't
as exhaustive as this one right and
um do people have a sense of
what a better way would be or would you
like a hint and anyone want to
conjecture a different way of solving
this problem that's
yeah go ahead
so the exhaustiveness of this algorithm
is as follows so basically what i'm
saying is
uh what i'm saying is i'm going to go
look at the range of times
and all of these are per hour right
everything is is per hour
i'm going to look at the range of times
and i'm going to go ahead
and uh and include um
a 6 through 12 here right and i'm going
to go 6
and i'm going to go figure out at six um
how many celebrities exist
and then at seven how many celebrities
exist and then at eight
all the way to twelve right and i'm
going to get uh
in count which is that uh list there i'm
going to get
for each uh for uh for count six
i'm going to say two and for count
uh 10 i'm going to get three
right because 10 is is the hour and then
i'm going to go through that list and
figure out that 10
had the maximum number in it and that's
the exhaustiveness
right that makes sense right so so if
you're good with that
this algorithm works but it's a little
painful right
um and so so what's what any ideas as to
how we could do things
uh quite differently which would be more
more efficient
it's uh and let me let me give out the
word i want i want
an incremental way of doing this
right how how could i do this
i have a starting time and
um i want to compute the same densities
in a in an incremental way okay
someone else other than 40.
um yeah back there um
well so you have to start in the end
time and you just for each
list of whatever you hold time yeah
you could keep like a account a
different account like a dictionary of
that
the start time and then increment
through each of the start times until
the end and just add
one each time so you're basically
iterating through each set of times
and finding the count of each time you
know whichever type is the most right
yeah
you're absolutely on the right track and
it turns out you don't even need
dictionaries
you can do this with just plain lists
but the idea here is it's actually a
very compelling one
it's something that you'll see in other
algorithms um you whenever you have
something where you're doing
repeated uh computation there's always
many a time there's a way of of uh of
of removing redundancy and turning it
into incremental computation
right and so the inside here is the
following
the only time that celebrity
uh density which is the number of
celebrities that are in the room
changes is obviously when a celebrity
enters
or when a celebrity leaves right i mean
that's it
i mean you know we're all celebrities
here you know and and uh
uh i guess we did have someone leave so
there you go and then maybe someone is
gonna come in
right so so i just need to monitor
uh um you know sort of input and output
or entry and exit
okay so and i also know what the end
points are
with respect to uh the sixth time six pm
versus
versus twelve correct so what i can do
here
is the following um
suppose suppose i had
a chart that looks like this
right and what i'm drawing here
is are these intervals they're not
exactly what i had up there
but i'm drawing those intervals out
right so you could think of this
if you like
as being six you can think of
these two lined up as being
seven and so on and so forth okay
so um so i could draw these out and and
i don't really have to draw these out in
a in a computer program but i can
certainly
draw them out uh in in terms of
giving you the intuition right so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to start
with zero so before six there's
absolutely no one in the room
so i'm at zero okay and
the moment i see um i i i
i take one of these things and if i if i
see a celebrity
um i can increment the count so here i
get
at five i'm at zero at six i get one
and and at seven
no one has left and two more people have
come in
so i get three okay
and now the next thing happens out here
um let's say this one here is eight
i would get four for that and then out
here
it's nine i go four minus one equals
three
because this this celebrity left okay
so um so essentially what i want to do
is not have to uh compute
this over and over for every time
running through all of the
list of celebrities like i did before
right for six i went through all the
celebrities for seven i went through all
the celebrities
but if i sort the celebrities
in um increasing order
of start times essentially this picture
is important and it requires sorting
because i went from left to right right
and when i go from left to right um i'm
essentially saying
i want to see things that come earlier
before
the ones that come later right that's
essentially what time goes to the right
right so i'm going from left to right so
if i take these intervals
and i sort them okay and
basically sort them by the by the by the
start times
then all i need to do is
in the sorted list of intervals i just
showed you the computation that we have
to perform
okay the computation that we have to
perform is this was the first interval
in the sorted list of intervals
right because it was the leftmost
interval and i take that and i go ahead
and increment it to one
right then um the next thing i do
is i don't have to worry about uh um at
any time even if there was a time if
this was six and this was eight for
example
um as long as there's no celebrity that
came
in at seven there's no reason for me to
change
uh anything in my data structure right
the only times that are interesting
are when celebrities enter and leave
okay
so the other nice thing about this
algorithm is that
um it will work if beyonce came in at 6
39
you know 39 you know 39 seconds 39
minutes 39 seconds and left
you know at 6 51 whatever right because
i'm only concerned with uh the entry
of a celebrity and the exit of a
celebrity that correspond to these
uh these points that you see here right
does that does the algorithm make sense
from an intuitive standpoint
right you see what's happening here it
hopefully the picture
gives you a gives you a sense for how
you're doing the correct computation
and the only times that things change
are when at the end points of these
intervals
right when you see someone increment
when you when someone leaves
decrement right so this
um set of numbers that you generate
is essentially the density down at the
bottom that
corresponds to
a particular times not necessarily on
the hour
but whenever the celebrities come and go
right and so
that a list that you get is all that you
need to look at
um to figure out what the maximum is
right so
ultimately down below in this particular
example perhaps four
was uh the maximum right and it
it started with zero it climbs up you
know maybe goes to four maybe goes to
five
and then goes down again maybe climbs up
again who cares you know you it
once you get to the point where you've
written a program size doesn't matter
anymore
right so the last thing i'll do is i'll
show you the code for this
it'll be up on the website and feel free
to
come to office hours and ask me
questions about the code or
before uh lecture tomorrow uh but
this is you know the entirety of the
code and i'm not even using
the built-in sort functions in python
right i mean i went ahead and wrote it
just to give you a sense of
how long the code would be but it's a
much more elegant algorithm
it would run faster on large examples
and i don't want to get into asymptotic
complexity that's really
um beyond this class but
as you can imagine rather than going
through the the
list of celebrities over and over we're
actually doing sorting exactly once
right so uh so that's that's better but
essentially what happens here
is is simple um you go ahead and you
create
um each of these times so this is
particular celebrity particular time and
this is the start point of the celebrity
so you you have to mark that
this is very different from that what
happens here
is i am adding
what happens here is i'm subtracting
right so i have to know
whether this point is very different
from that point this is the same as that
same as that and all of these are
similar but i have to differentiate
between the two
for obvious reasons right so i have to
have start and end
and then i i go ahead and take these
times each of these times that you see
with these black dots here they all need
to be sorted
because that's the only way i'm going to
go from left to right
right that's the only way by going
through that
list of times right so i'm going to go
ahead and do that sorting and i could
have done times dot sort by the way i
don't have to have
um sort list but i just as i said i
wanted to show you the
the code without using any python
library functions
and then i and then choose time is
simply looking through that list finding
that maximum number
be it four or five and returning the
index of that because that tells you
what the
what the particular time is and that
time will always be
um can someone tell me last question and
i'll let you go
what what am i what am i going to get
on any given example what am i going to
get
as the best time any given example
i'll get to you if if uh
yeah a time when more people come and
leave
at time when more people come to leave
that's that's correct but i want
something stronger
what's your name josh josh yeah josh is
right but i want something even stronger
than
uh than a time that uh more people come
than leave
i mean it's it's it's it's correct uh
but uh a variant uh uh observation
someone else i i wanna say something
about
um there's two sets of points here right
um
there's two sets of points here which
point which set of points
are going to be the ones that are in
play
with respect to the maximum time right
that's maybe a better question
right go ahead
the arrival time that's right the
arrival time of a celebrity right and
it's true that what you said
george is correct ultimately the best
time is going to be
when uh the maximum number of uh
arrivals happen
right uh but at the bottom line is i'm
never going to
i'm never going to see this is actually
an interesting observation and there's
an exercise related to this observation
for this puzzle that you might want to
look at that i'll put up on on the
website
as soon as we're done here you're you're
always going to pick one of these
beginning times because that's when the
increment happens you'd never pick one
of these because that's when a decrement
happens right
so so that's all i wanted to say and and
the reason i wanted to say that as i
said there's a there's an extra question
on top of this and yet another algorithm
to solve this
that is really based on that final
observation that we made
all right well thank you sorry for going
over but as i said
this is iap forgive me